hallo ihr lieben ich backe heute meine
eigene geburtstagstorte das ist nämlich
der vorteil wenn jeder aus seinem umfeld
weiß dass du gerne backt man kriegt man
keine mehr dann macht man sie sich eben
selber und wir machen ein richtig
leckere mit vanille biscuit einem white
chocolate frosting ich liebe alles was
mit weißer schokolade zu tun und ein
bisschen frucht ist auch noch mit dabei
fürs gute gewissen und jetzt zeige ich
euch hier die zutaten
hier habe ich meinen vanille bis geboten
gebacken das rezept dazu das findet ihr
schon auf meinem kanal ich habe hier die
mengenangaben wie im rezept genommen mit
dem einzigen unterschied dass sich das
in 2 22 cm springform gebacken habe des
weiteren haben wir hier etwas sahne
außerdem weiße kuvertüre gehackt
puderzucker weiche butter etwas
aprikosenmarmelade und mandarin aus der
dose wir starten jetzt zuallererst mit
der weißen kuvertüre und der saane die
sahne habe ich mir gerade in der
mikrowelle erhitzt so dass die gerade
anfing hochzusteigen und jetzt gebe ich
es einmal über die gehackte weiße
kuvertüre und jetzt den deckel drauf
geben und 5 minuten ruhen lassen
nach fünf minuten ist die schokolade
schon so ein bisschen in der heißen
sonne geschmolzen und jetzt nehmen wir
uns unseren schneebesen und verrühren
das einmal das ist alles schön glatt ist
so jetzt ist alles gut miteinander
verbunden und wir haben eine homogene
masse
die muss jetzt allerdings auskühlen das
dauert 20 bis 30 minuten dann können wir
sie es weiter verarbeiten so die garage
ist jetzt abgekühlt und wir können
weitermachen unter frosting besteht ja
aus der nase und aus butter und
puderzucker
ich habe jetzt die weiche butter
beziehungsweise zimmer waren butter in
die schüssel einer küchenmaschine
ihr könnt aber auch allerhand gerät
verwenden dauert es ein bisschen länger
jetzt gebe ich es einmal rein
puderzucker gleich hinterher und dann
wird das schön cremig aufgeschlagen
fünf minuten hat das ganze jetzt bei mir
gedauert in der küchenmaschine mit dem
handrührgerät schlag die butter etwa
acht minuten lang cremig und dann ist
sie richtig schön hell und an der stelle
geben wir jetzt auch noch die gagen
treiben und arbeiten in einem dünnen
strahl mit ein richtiger nach auch mit
drin alles schön untergerührt und jetzt
ist unser frosting beziehungsweise die
white chocolate buttercreme auch schon
fertig an der stelle ist es noch ein
bisschen weich aber ich gebe euch einen
tipp falls ihr das besser verstreichen
könnt auf dem kuchen wenn es etwas
härter ist als das jetzt dann gibt es
einfach in den kühlschrank für etwa 20
minuten rückständig und dann könnt ihr
das ganz einfach einstreichen
um unsere geburtstagstorte jetzt fertig
zu stellen müssen wir zuallererst die
böden durch schneiden hier habe ich noch
einen kleinen tipp für euch damit eure
böden nicht austrocknen einfach etwas
feuchtes küchentuch drumherum bedingt
oder in frischhaltefolie einwickeln
je nachdem was der gerade da habt und
jetzt werde ich die einmal in der mitte
halbieren so dass ich vier bühnen
insgesamt erhalte
und jetzt werden wir die torte nur noch
zusammen stellen ich habe mir dafür
meine süße tortenplatte zurechtgelegt
das ist so eine kleine meine lieblings
tortenplatte die hat der haben sie mir
mal geholt
und genau da werde ich das ganze stapel
und da müssen wir auch nicht hin und her
transportieren ist nämlich mit den
ersten boden legt den drauf und dann
geben wir da noch unsere aprikosen
gerade drauf und man reden und
anschließend wie creme dann stapeln wie
immer so weiter
und falls es ganz gerade haben möchte
und so ein bisschen hilfe braucht dann
gibt er ruhig so einen kram drumherum
dann könnt ihr das auch richtig
ordentlich stapeln
[Musik]
und falls ihr euch jetzt fragt ob ich
irgendwas austauschen könnte das ist gar
kein thema falls ihr kirchen da hat gibt
die gerne rein bananen tasten auch super
erdbeeren die man gerne auch tiefkühl
früchte und die marmelade könnt ihr auch
durch jede beliebige andere austauschen
oder durch nuss nougat creme ist auch
super lecker
[Musik]
jetzt ist die torte randvoll gefüllt
jetzt gebe ich nur noch den deckel drauf
und zum abschluss nämlich gerne so ein
richtig gerade stück das ist der
tortenboden also das untere teil gewesen
einfach drauf geben frischhaltefolie
darüber geben damit es auch nicht
austrocknet und dann muss es einmal
durch kühn am besten eine bis eineinhalb
stunden und dann machen noch weiter ja
weil viele sind immer ungeduldig man
muss das so lange kühn aber dann wird
einfach lockerer
so also bis gleich nach der kür zeit
müssen wir jetzt einmal das äußere
komplett einstreichen ich hatte die
buttercreme in der zwischenzeit auch im
kühlschrank und nicht dass der kuchen
richtig schön fest einmal schön glatt
einstreichen und dann geht sie mich
weiter mit der finalen dekoration
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann mit der torte zufrieden
sein und sie rundherum eingestrichen
haben gehen wir an den unteren rand noch
konfetti oder streusel also essbares
konfetti und danach wird sie wieder
eingefangen aber jetzt kümmern wir uns
erst mal um die bunten streuseln
[Musik]
so ihr lieben meine torte ist jetzt im
gefrierfach ich habe mir da wie gesagt
ein bisschen platz gemacht da dauert
ungefähr 20 minuten bis es hart wird im
kühlschrank denke ich so 30 bis 40
minuten und ein teil der creme habe ich
mir jetzt an die seite getan einem
spritzbeutel damit ich gleich noch mal
einen kuchen richtig schön dekorieren
kann und für die weitere dekoration wir
machen nämlich einen dropkick benötigen
wir außerdem noch weiße kuvertüre die
habe ich fein gehackt zwar ein bisschen
drüber aber das macht nichts
außerdem etwas sahne und hier habe ich
pinke lebensmittelfarbe dass sgl farbe
und die ruhe ich sofort in die sahne 1
und anschließend wird die sahne
aufgekocht
[Musik]
dieser habe ich jetzt erneut in der
mikrowelle aufkochen das gleiche prinzip
wie gerade die gebe ich jetzt auch mit
zug ouvertüre decke das ab und dann
lassen wir das fünf minuten stehen etwas
an schmelzen und dann wird das ganze
verrührt
[Musik]
nachdem fünf minuten verrinnen wir
wieder alles miteinander bis wir eine
homogene masse erhalten und so könnte
eben gerne sterben nur über türe färben
mit passten farbe funktioniert nicht
dann wird sich alles lösen und ihr
würdet münchen erhalten dafür braucht
man schon so bestimmte pulver farbe die
fettlöslich ist aber das ist eben eine
super alternative
dann braucht ihr keine candy mails
kaufen wir sind ja auch nicht gerade
günstig genau das war ruhig das
miteinander und dann sehen wir mal das
endergebnis so fertig eingefärbt und ich
finde die farbe sieht richtig cool aus
ihr könnt natürlich auch jede andere
farbe nehmen falls zum beispiel jemand
geburtstag hat der männlich ist könnt
ihr euch hier blaue farbe rein mission
ganz viel möchtet oder jemand hat einen
lieblings habe das geht auch und jetzt
gebe ich das einfach auf die oberfläche
und vorteil dass so mit meiner wenige
palette dass es an den seiten runter
tropft
[Musik]
nachdem wir unseren drift runter fließen
lassen haben habe ich das noch mal kurz
im kühlschrank gegeben damit das fest
ist dass dort auch mit zehn minuten also
nicht allzu lang und jetzt gehen wir
eben noch drauf und dann haben wir den
kuchen fertig dekoriert
[Musik]
und habe ich euch nicht gesagt wenn ihr
diese torte seht dann werdet ihr sagen
das ist die ultimative geburtstagstorte
die schreibt nur so nach happy birthday
finde ich genau für mädchen wegen der
farbe muss ich sein
ich sitze auch jungs die mövenpick am sa
kann ja auch sein ansonsten könnt ihr
auch gerne andere farben auf jeden fall
super lecker ich kenne ja die
buttercreme schon gefällt mir super gut
mit der weiße schokolade mit den
früchten ein super ausgleich und alle
genauen zutaten findet ihr hier und
nehmen der infobox ein memo noch an mich
selbst nie wieder mit fledermaus m in
kuchen backen also ist total dreckig
kann euch mal zeigen sieht man das ja
schade egal
man lernt ja auch immer was dazu ich
wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen interesse dem video gerne ein
like und ein kommentar und abonniert
main kanal kostenlos damit ihr auch
nichts mehr verpasst und dann freue ich
mich wenn wir uns auch beim nächsten mal
sehen ist erst morgen aber danke
[Musik]